now an ecological disaster that has
puzzled been scientists from poland and
germany for
weeks now vast numbers of fish washed up
dead in the river that runs between the
two countries the oda now
researchers think they may have an
answer
the danger is invisible to the naked eye
a microscopic species of algae could be
to blame for the mass deaths of fish in
the river order along the border between
germany and poland officials on the
german side alone have recovered 36 tons
of dead fish on the polish side the fire
department reports nearly 100 tons
researchers have been trying to find out
why now their tests have discovered an
unusually high concentration of the
microalgae species pregnasium parvum
which should not even be in rivers
but water experts think the algae's
toxins could be behind this ecological
catastrophe
they go into the gills and from there
they can destroy blood vessels but they
also attack mussels and amphibians and
since i've also seen dead mussels on the
odor as well as dead fish i believe this
is the cause
this species of algae normally lives in
river mouths where fresh and salt water
mix
that's why some scientists suspect that
salt discharged into the order river
might have led to the buildup of algae
it could be at least another week before
this is clarified
let's get an expert view on this daniel
helling is a professor whose research
focuses on aquatic ecology he's at the
university of duisburg essen thanks for
being with us professor hailing how
likely is it do you think that algae are
responsible for the massive fish kill in
the oda river
so first let me underline that i was not
personally involved in this
investigation
but to me it sounds very likely a very
likely cause so we observe um
observed in the beginning of august uh
massive
increase in conductivity
of the of the odor conductivity is an
indicator for the salt content
and about a week later
apparently we had a very high
concentration of algae a so-called algae
bloom
and these algae blooms are generally
very dangerous for fishes especially in
the summer so
yeah if it is stock science or if
the algae have caused in another way
this is still to be investigated but uh
it is most likely that the algae play a
big role
okay so uh
plausible for sure if it is algae do you
think it would be attributable to human
activity and pollution
most likely not so the theology the
colleagues at the igb berlin have
identified
uh is as you just said
in the short presentation there's an
allergy that produce toxins sometimes
that are dangerous for fish and all
other
organisms that have gills
so for for humans and also for other
mammals it is less likely that we are
affected
um but let me also underline that uh
well
this
uh question
if talks science play a role
is not yet clarified but uh such a
massive algae bloom
uh
has in any in any case a
strong effect on fishes
so what we also observed here is the ph
value of water it
went above
the value of nine
and this is always critical for fish
because under these conditions
of massive photosynthesis of algae which
causes then this increase in ph
then
ammonium which is always in the water is
transferred to ammoniac so it can simply
be also
intoxication by ammoniac this could also
have been
caused by the algae and this is from my
point of view the most likely boss
okay so it's clear that more research
has to be done to find out what exactly
has happened there but do you think
given what you know so far that it will
be possible to restore the river to full
health because this is an important
river
yeah certainly it also has a very
important fish population also with
several species that are just occurring
in this river so called endemic species
um at least two there was also a kind of
reintroduction program of the uh of a
sturgeon specie and this is certainly
also affected
so um
i think
uh the river will recover
because the
tributaries of the river have apparently
not affected and certainly also some
fish have survived and also of the
invertebrates several will have survived
which can be a kind of initial source
for a rebuilding
population
on the other hand it underlines very
very strongly how close to ecological
tipping points all our rivers are in
these very hot summers there's little
discharge there's a very high
temperatures and all the organisms that
live in the river they are
all almost very close to our collapse
all right and if then for example
or the effluent of salt or something
like this that
comes comes on top
then we very often have these sort of
fish goods
professor daniel herring thank you very
much
thank you
you